what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are officially getting into
infinity countdown prime number one and
in truth where the infinity countdown
Adam warlock story just kind of showed
us where Adam warlock was infinity
countdown prime actually gives us the
Infinity stones and it's basically like
this race for the Infinity stones so for
those of you guys who read like Thanos
quest imagine that story but instead of
it just being Thanos it's like a bunch
of people trying to find the Infinity
stones and gain them for themselves now
the cool thing about this and this is
something that I want you guys to notice
as we kind of kicked us off is that the
Infinity stones historically speaking in
terms of their purpose and the role
they've played has almost always been
consistent the only change the only
fluctuation that came to with the
Infinity stones was like their color but
one of the other big changes here and
this is actually a pretty significant
deviation is the reality stone
historically speaking the reality stone
allowed a user to manipulate the fabric
of reality but it didn't allow them to
do anything they wanted to like you
couldn't use the reality stone to read
everyone's minds or you couldn't use the
reality stone till I travel back and
forth through time that was the kind of
caveat that jim Starlin and guys like
roy thomas and so on created when they
created the Infinity stones what the
reality stone can now do in Marvel
Comics is it can allow an individual to
access the multiverse and again that was
never the case you were never able to
access the multiverse before one of the
things that was established really in
like a handful of different stories over
the years it was established in JLA
versus Avengers I think and it was
established and like Jonathan Hickman's
fantastic I'm sorry Jonathan Hickman
Avengers and New Avengers
the Infinity golem that only works in
its native reality so if for example you
took the Infinity Gauntlet from the main
Marvel Universe and then you went to
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it wouldn't work it would just be a
glove with some gems on it and that
would be about it it would look really
fancy and you could probably pawn it but
like there wouldn't be anything that
you'd be able to do with it in terms of
like using its power now from here I
want to jump into the main story itself
because what this does is it initially
picks up with classic Wolverine and the
reason why I say classic is classic
Wolverine died in the death of
Wolverines storyline there were actually
two versions there's two versions that
need to be aware of the first is by greg
rucka and I can't remember for the life
of me who it was that wrote the second
one actually now that I think about it
it was Charles Soule that's who it was
the row Thea the the death of Wolverine
but it was basically away from over like
get rid of Wolverine and in its place
they gave us like old man Logan old man
Logan basically moved into the main
Marvel Universe after the events of
seeker wars what we got
with the Morfitt legacy one shot is who
basically got the return of classic
Wolverine we didn't really know how he
came back we just know that he did and
he was basically sporting the space
stone so it was kind of like okay like
how in the world did he get his hands on
that now the idea here is that he's just
kind of been meandering around and I'm
always been covering that I think we're
supposed to be in the back of every
single comic but I think it's only in
the back of select comics where you
basically figure out like what did what
it is a classic Wolverines been doing
and it's supposed to come to a head I
think with the actual like infinity
countdown the Grand Poobah story the big
summer event is what he's supposed to
get like that one shot that basically
takes all those little mini reveals and
then puts them all into a single story
which is actually a pretty cool idea but
the fact remains a classic Wolverine is
just kind of been roaming around the
Marvel Universe and that's really about
it but he's basically tracked down by
Ultron's drones it's really the best way
to think about it now the one thing to
bear in mind here when it comes to
Ultron is you have the main Ultron robot
and then you have the Ultron drones the
fact that Ultron is basically an AI that
just kind of becomes self-aware and
basically became Skynet is away from all
to kind of bring his character back time
and time again but it's also a way for
Marvel to use his character in
interesting ways for example
annihilation conquest was when Ultron
took over the Phalanx basically a
cybernetic race of beings and then in
turn tried to conquer the universe so it
was a cool story in terms of how that
happened but it was the idea that Ultron
basically just kind of has drones that
go about and do his bidding now
Wolverine has fought Ultron enough for
the past to be well aware of what it is
that's happening but as far as I'm aware
these are not like adamantium drones and
wolverine makes kriti quick work of them
I mean Ultron's kind of watching all
this unfold and this is just one of
those circumstances we're all trying to
basically just grab various organisms
and then just kind of imprinted itself
onto them and then they basically became
drones for them but you know almost
immediately after these drones are
basically eradicated we end up having
the arrival of Loki now for those of you
guys who are familiar with what's going
on and Loki with Loki and Doctor Strange
please do not spoil anything because we
will cover that but the fact remains
here it's kind of funny because when
Loki first pops up he actually slashes
will rain across the face and it's just
like hey I just want to make sure it's
you and like if you hear yourself then
like you know we'll know it's you and
then Wolverine stabs him through the
head and it's like hey man I just want
to make sure it's you it's one of those
funny exchanges the two of them have
because remember despite the fact that
we might find it entertaining
historically speaking of Marvel Comics
Wolverine hates Loki like he absolutely
despises Loki
it was kind of funny to see the two of
them interact and
sort of mess with each other now of
course Wolverines kind of going on and
doing his own thing we don't really know
exactly what he's trying to do we just
know he has a space stone and that's
really about it but again the idea is to
kind of keep it from falling into the
wrong hands this is pretty smart because
remember when it comes to the Infinity
stones if the wrong person gets you know
any one of the stones then they can
basically unify them that's one of the
things that was established and Brian
Michael Bendis is a Illuminati
miniseries we found out when Reed
Richards basically first gained one of
the Infinity stones that the stones want
to come back together they want to be
unified so if you capture one you should
be able to find all the others and sub
Loki's advice here is look man be
careful walking around with that stone
because if you have it other people will
come for it at this point we actually
pick up with a guy named Turk Barrett
Turk Barrett was originally introduced
back in 1969 I'm sorry 1970 with
daredevil issue number 69 and he's one
of those street-level characters that's
just been around he's been like a
henchman he's been an information broker
he's been a middleman he's been an
errand runner but he was never like a
super significant character but
somewhere along the line Turk Barrett
managed to get his hands on the mine
stone we have no earthly clue how it was
that he got ahold of this we just know
that he did but again this is designed
to basically say that if a person's in
possession of a stone they will use it
for any number of means and this sort of
narration that we get here is that it's
in the nature of humanity to be that way
you know ever every single time we've
seen the Infinity stones in Marvel
Comics it's always gone that way I mean
even if you look at like the Illuminati
miniseries you know the Illuminati one
shot I guess really the one of the
stories of the five stories that were
there when Reed Richards brought the
Infinity Gauntlet together originally
when The Watcher showed up and said like
you have to put it down like you have to
get rid of the Infinity Gauntlet Reed
didn't want to he didn't want to
dismantle it Charles Xavier made him do
it he basically used his mental powers
and like trick the Richards that took
the mind of Reed Richards in order to
make him like say okay well yeah I guess
I should get rid of it even the most
staunch of individuals can be corrupted
by the Infinity Gauntlet
the only exception of that that I can
think of really was two instances one
was iron man and the other was Captain
America with iron man it was like a a
one-shot story I think it was with
Captain America it was an Avengers and
New Avengers basically when they tried
to stop the incursions and he used the
Infinity Gauntlet and was like oh my god
this is so much power and ultimately it
didn't work and the stone shattered but
even then it was for like maybe ten
seconds that he actually had the gun
on his hand the other half of this and
this is where things get kind of a
little weird here
as we switch over to like Carol Danvers
with the reality stone but we also get
like basically Monica Rambeau we get
like you know a Captain Marvel and the
image kind of goes on and on it's kind
of like one of these things where sort
of cascades off panel itself and the
indication is that the reality stone
exists in like all these different
realities or basically it was Carol
Danvers hopping from universe to
universe or something along those lines
we're not really given an explicit
definition here it is kind of weird but
it's really just kind of like a splash
page designed to say the reality stone
allows its user to basically tap into
other universes to essentially access
other universes now we also know what's
going on with a Power Stone right like
we covered that in the guardians of the
galaxy story where we basically dealt
with like the return of Adam warlock
different things like that and the idea
is that the Power Stone is now this
massive rock it's kind of an interesting
thing when it comes to that but again
people are on the hunt for it like
people are searching around for these
various artifacts for example we end up
coming across the super scroll who it
looks like he's in possession of the
time stone and this is cool because
super scrolls are character that we
haven't seen in quite some time those of
you guys who don't know
super scroll is a guy named Clerk he's
literally a scroll but the difference
between him and other Scrolls is he
basically has all the powers of the
Fantastic Four he could access those
powers and transform himself into any
one of the Fantastic Four or use all
their powers at the same time if he
wants to so it's kind of interesting but
much like a lot of the scrolls that
exist out there because of the fact that
the race is kind of waxed and waned over
the years in the sense that there's been
a lot of social upheavals and civil wars
and there's been massive conflict and
the scrolls have been defeated and their
planet was destroyed by Galactus the
idea of super scroll is to say I will
return the Empire to its glory meaning
he will use a time stone to travel back
in time and at some point along the line
correct things that had gone wrong now
in truth the introduction of the time
stone are kind of like the the
reintroduction of the time stone into
the Marvel Comics universe right now is
actually pretty significant because what
would happen if someone got a hold of
the time stone and then went back before
Secret Wars happen and basically said
hey guys so here's what's causing the
whole collapse of the multiverse like
what if so I decided to go all the way
back and basically stop Secret Wars from
happening or stop Doctor Doom from like
defeating the beyonders or basically
explain everything to Reed Richards
there's a lot of possibilities the cool
thing about the time stone is that the
time stone is basically a gateway to
like a reboot
wanted to of course we also have Adam
warlock who finally emerges from his
imprisonment like we discussed in the
whole Adam warlock story again that's
the idea here is this kind of this
notion that like a lot of people are
chasing after the stones vandals of
course is on the hunt for the Infinity
stones because you know it's it's an
infinity stone story and what would an
infinity stone story be without Thanos
so I mean you gotta have them in there
somewhere but we also get this really
cool moment where we actually end up
having ego the Living Planet it's not
necessarily talking directly with with
the magnets but kind of having a bit of
a kind of observing everything that's
going on now The Magus is interesting in
Marvel comics and a lot of people are
not really familiar with him we talked
about him in our video on Adam warlock
and to keep it really short here to sum
it up and you know ten seconds the Magus
is basically like an alternate reality
future version of Adam warlock
it's basically what would happen if Adam
warlock became a bad guy and the idea
was that Adam warlock wants to retain
the soul Jim because remember when it
comes to like Adam warlock when it comes
to the magnets they're kind of part and
parcel to the soul Jim itself the Magus
came into existence because of like
prolonged exposure to the soul Jim by
Adam warlock at the same time Adam
warlock has been confined inside soul
world which is in the soul stone so by
one measure or another each character is
basically tightly intertwined with the
nature of the soul stone itself but for
the Magus what he's actually doing here
is having a conversation with the
contemplate er now the contemplate er is
one of the elders of the universe
basically one of the like the last
surviving member of his own race
the contemplate er is a guy who
basically realized that if he's in tune
with himself in perfect harmony he can
actually jump from one universe to
another using an astral form so it was
kind of cool yeah that's his little
caveat thing but having been in
existence for like billions of years
he's got untold wisdom and is kind of
cool with the Magus talking to her
because the Magus is trying to find out
where the soul stone is the problem is
that with him having it in his
possession he's immediately attacked and
killed by Ultron and so this is kind of
interesting because Magus is out of the
picture now and honestly I would have
would have made the gamble as said you
know the Magus is the one who's
basically doing all this The Magus is
the one who's basically gathering all
the Infinity stones he's gonna be the
main villain it seems like one of these
things where Marvel's trying to avoid
that that's what happened in infinity
war The Magus the evil version of Adam
warlock started gathering all the
Infinity stones reformed the Infinity
Gauntlet and had all the cosmic cubes
from like these different universes and
so on and so forth it was pandemonium
but Marvel's already done this dance
once before and so it wouldn't make any
sense to do the dance all over again you
got to move on
to a different dance so that's kind of
the cool thing here and the funny thing
about this is that what is up happening
is that when it comes to the contemplate
er talking to you know PEM Tron really
is what we can kind of call him you know
easily says look you don't know what
you're getting into by wielding this
thing and it's true you know it's it's
true because PIM Tron's never held the
soul stone before what did he keep in
mind if you hold the soul stone long
enough if you have it in your possession
long enough and you do not guard
yourself adequately it will start
siphoning off your soul and so
eventually if your soul will reside
inside the soul stone you'll never be
able to get out and that's exactly what
happens here in this instance we
basically end up finding out that where
there's this kind of psychic backlash
basically this kind of feedback where a
portion of pintron soul is literally
yanked inside of the of the soul stone
itself we end up having like you know
hank pym being the one who's confined in
there essentially meaning that PIM Tron
seems to be 100% Ultron now and Hank Pym
himself is just confined inside of the
soul stone where he's ultimately met
with the soul of Gomorrah you know
another counterpart to the Gomorrah that
kind of runs around right now and this
counterpart simply says you're stuck in
here forever now there's no conceivable
way for you to get out now Adam warlock
could enter into soul world and he could
take their souls and bring them out
there's a lot of ways for them to be
able to get out but notice this like
they've been aging that's the difference
here gomorrah has been aging since she's
been in here she's grown older time has
passed inside of soul world something
else that I also want you guys to notice
too is that this depiction of soul world
is historically vastly different from
the way that it used to be in Marvel
Comics the soul world has always been
depicted as a sort of idyllic paradise
effectively heaven for the most part and
there's just complete and total peace
there's no war no conflict no anything
like that so if your soul gets locked
away it's actually not the worst place
to be and this instance is kind of
depicted as being like a barren
landscape now I don't know if that's
meant to hit anything I don't know if
that's just the current depiction of the
soul world by you know the artist of the
story I'm not a hundred percent sure I
mean it could mean nothing it could mean
everything I don't know
but what this does is this leads
directly into the main infinity
countdown story going into the story and
a huge summer event that kind of you
know concludes in July and so on and so
forth but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]